this guy built this
this mansion paul
in uh
in los angeles
that he was going to try to sell for 500
million dollars
that's like a resort in hawaii well
there's a nightclub it's the actual size
of a nightclub there's a movie theater
it's the actual size of a movie theater
it's the biggest environmental disaster
i've ever seen in my life there it is
what what
yeah i'm bowling i forgot the bowling
alley a tennis court oh my god plus plus
all right you see the pool up top
where'd you go right there it's got a
glass wall around it like you're in the
pool you can see the whole person no
matter how much you're underwater that's
off that's your pool
for that's the uh what do you call the
master bedroom that also has a kitchen
and it has its own pool and you can
literally jump off of that pool i
wouldn't recommend it into the end of
the main pool